my first question for you is what are
the some of the things you love and hate
about being on camera especially YouTube
because you guys are on camera on your
own and also with the um documentary
crew so how is that for the both of you
I think what could be difficult for us
is we get very comfortable with the
people that we are with every day and
who are in our house so we are ourselves
and I feel like sometimes when you get
so comfortable you like
don't always have like the smile on your
face or think of every single word you
say because there is like someone
filming in your bedroom or whatever
um so I think that's a hard struggle to
remember like people are gonna see this
and have opinions on you so
maybe don't be so relaxed all the time
what about you Charlie yeah I think
there's times throughout filming when
you really have to
you know understand that there is a
difference between
just talking or like saying something In
the Heat of the Moment and the fact that
well this is gonna come out however many
months later and I probably won't even
remember what I was upset about yeah and
I think it's just
trying to understand that but also
wanting to be as real as possible
throughout the show I think it's just
figuring out that balance that's a
little bit difficult yeah it sounds
difficult I mean I I don't envy in that
where I can I could not be on camera all
the time I'd be a high class so
for that
um so I'm going to ask you people
specific questions I'm gonna start with
Charlie Charlie
um it sound in one of the episodes you
talked about college and wanting to go
to school and
my question for you is why not what's
stopping you I mean
I think as of right now there's a few
things stopping me
um
but I think if it was something that I
actually
really deep down wanted to do I could
make it possible it's just I don't think
it's in the cards right now but it's
definitely something that is in the back
of my mind sometimes that it would be
cool to get the college experience but
that's not something that I really feel
would fit in with my schedule or what
I'm doing right now
um just because
I don't think if I were to go to school
right now it would be my first priority
which if I went I would want to
obviously do as well as possible
um
so yeah I don't know I guess that's a
it's a me thing if I wanted to I re I
could you know that makes sense it's a
you thing too you'll go if you want to
when you're ready yeah absolutely now
I'm turning to you Dixie um you have
been very open with your struggles with
pmdd and I know I mean my friend just
got diagnosed with it so it's something
that not a lot of people are aware of
um and some people you know kind of
downplay it but it is very serious and
you're going through it on camera how
why did you opt to share that part of
your life I just think it was just such
a big answer for a lot of questions that
I've had for years for me and I feel
like need to share that because
it's not normal to feel those ways like
two weeks out of the month every month
and dealing with that and realizing a
lot of people probably deal with it and
no one even knows or they get
misdiagnosed with something else I
thought it was really important to share
and
also being aware of it has helped my
relationship with like friends and my
family and
our relationship
because we just know how to handle each
other better now that makes sense that
makes sense and it is definitely good
for people to continue to learn about it
so I know I'm appreciative like my
friend is appreciative of seeing it on
display on camera I have a few more
questions
um the first one being uh your careers
are kind of Shifting right they're in
flux right you're moving from social
media and now you're in the realm of
reality TV
um how do you feel social media has
helped and hurt
that process I think it's helped because
people found out from us on social media
and now
um want to see more into our lives and I
think it probably hurt because
we didn't know how much of our Lives we
were going to be putting out there I
mean when we signed up for this we were
told it's a docu-series and I think the
first season was
very dramatic but the most like
vulnerable out of all of us and then now
it's like reality show so we just didn't
know exactly what we were signing up for
but I think it's interesting and kind of
something I feel like a lot of families
are like oh we should have a reality
show
and now we're doing it nice Charlie what
about you yeah I think definitely agree
with everything that you said it's
obviously we wouldn't have a show
without social media so it's a big
that's you know how the connection was
made and why anyone cared to see what we
were doing in our day-to-day lives and I
think the only reason that it can hurt
is having to kind of like relive all the
stuff that we've already
been through all over again just because
this is now going to be everyone else's
first times seeing these situations
really happen got it got it so what is
one thing you would want viewers to take
away from this upcoming season I think
this season was very
um
filled with a lot of information and a
lot of things going on and
at the end of the day I think because
our family core is really strong and
we've
done a lot of work to build our
connection and keep our connection that
what
I didn't say no I know what was I saying
I have no idea oh yeah I didn't know
where you were going like we just
um
take away from the season like at the
end of the the day we're still a family
and we still have
people and lives and emotions and we're
going to have oh ups and downs and I
think this year was this season is a lot
of downs but I think we came through a
lot stronger and hopefully if another
season were to come we could see how
where we are now amazing well thank you
both so much I'm sorry I have to cut it
short
um I appreciate you taking the time to
talk to me from one girl with a sister
to another
um thank you